Alright, Sara, I did what you said I should never do, I styled a div.
>> Alright.
>> So, I gave it, I gave all div's black backgrounds, and I don't even
really know what this does, but I
said margin 100, what I'm guessing means pixels?
>> Pixels, yes
>> I saw that, you know.
>> So some of these are going to get overridden by
specific rules on like name divs that have class names, but.
>> Sara, you said I shouldn't do it.
>> No. Are you willing to put your money where, where your mouth is?
>> It's going
to look funny.
>> Yeah? Oh, crap. [LAUGH] It looks really. Hey, I'm still.
>> Hey, you're still playing.
>> I'm still doing well actually.
>> You're combing things somehow.
>> Yeah. Oh, my goodness. Oh, there they are.
>> You can probably see how to combine them here. Maybe.
>> Wow.
>> That's interesting.
>> Okay, so. [LAUGH] I guess, don't style your divs, is probably good advice.
>> Yeah.